- People don't understand the
feeling of going to school,
and you sit next to a friend, and that
same night, you hearing that friend was
murdered and you sitting in that same
desk that next day, and he's not there,
and you realize he’s not coming back here.
He didn't transfer to another school.
He didn't—he wasn't sick.
Like, he's not coming back, period.
- [Clapping]
- OK.
That good?
- That was a terrible cut, but—
- [Laughing]
- All right.
- All right, you ready, DeMar?
- Yeah.
- I'm Taylor Rooks, and these are
conversations about defining one's
relationship to Blackness and
how that defines their America.
OK, DeMar, same question
I ask everybody first on this series:
When did you realize that being
Black was different from being white?
- Playing basketball always gave me
the opportunity to see different
places, be around different places.
And I think the first time, I think I was
in ninth grade. We would—we drove out,
like, two hours away to this school,
this white community,
and I've seen for the first time
how different their schools were,
facilities, just everything about
that culture was like
night and day from us.
And it used to—from then on,
it used to make me question, like,
“Damn, why, why’s their stuff better?
Why they have this better?
Why they talk better?
Or why they dress better?
Or why—” So many questions came about,
you know, and as I continue to get older
and get older, I’ve seen the separation
from, you know, privilege, privilege,
to, you know, where we came from, you know,
getting everything, you know, feeling like
leftovers and making it work, you know?
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- Um, that's when I first started noticing it.
- When you noticed it, that disparity
and like the, just the huge, huge,
difference, how did that make you feel?
- It leaves you numb for a while
for me personally because you
was just trying to figure it out, you know?
And as I became older and started
to see things differently,
you know, it just always left a
question mark with a lot of things,
you know? And some I never even told
people out, out loud was when
I went to college, even though I went
to SC that was 15, 20 minutes away
from Compton, I had a culture shock.
Like, it was, it was the first time
that I was really consistently
around, you know, white people.
And you seeing
everybody with laptops,
talking with a different type of
vernacular. Like, the slang was out.
Like, it was so many things that was so
different from my culture, and it was
kinda intimidating, you know?
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- It was kind of intimidating because that was like the
first time where I'm in that environment
that, that didn't feel like
me or feel comfortable.
And I felt like they was looking
at me differently other than
just being an athlete, you know?
And it—that, that was kind
of a frustrating adjustment that
I had to get used to in college.
- How did you get used to it?
- It took a while.
Um, I didn't live—I didn't
stay on campus for my first
three, four months of college.
- Did you not stay on campus
because of the culture shock?
- Yeah.
It was just too much of a culture
shock, like, being around it.
And it was like, it was like, it
was a feeling that is so hard to
explain because I grew up in this
urban environment, and I felt like
that was the norm to go into that.
I couldn't imagine being—
going to University of Kentucky being
from L.A.. You know, being left out, trying
to figure this out on my own, but
it was rough.
It was, it was extremely rough.
And I just wanted to stay in my
element as long as possible
till I felt comfortable being on campus.
- Really?
- [DeMar:] Yeah.
- So when you kinda decided to go back to
campus and be around, you know, everybody
that was on campus, do you feel nervous?
Do you feel like you won't be accepted?
Like, what's the hesitation there?
- Yeah, being nervous. Not accepted.
Not having what they have. Not, you know,
not knowledgeable of,
of the freedom of movement that they have.
You know, people always think it's cool
for us as athletes, just to be an athlete.
But at the end of the day, we’re people.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- We’re human beings,
and we wanna be accepted that way.
So for me not to be able to comprehend
with a different culture and
knowing that my culture are
looked down upon in
a certain type of way
was frustrating.
So I shied away from it for a long time.
- You know, I wonder if we underestimate
the challenge that Black athletes
have going to white universities.
And honestly, I don't know if I ever
really sat and thought about it in
that way, cuz I'm seeing so much
of it from my experience. But a lot of
these athletes that go and play sports
are coming from areas where they
probably have not interacted
with a lot of white people.
- Right.
Right.
You know, I think, I think that definitely
goes unnoticed because it's,
it's one of those things to where it's
just college in itself is different. It's
hard for us being minorities coming from
where we come from to all of a sudden,
we’re sitting in these intimidating
classrooms with a different
type of culture that don't know us,
don't get, get us, you
know? And it's never been—
it's just always been an
acceptance factor, not feeling
like we was always accepted
unless we was an athlete or someone of,
or something instead of just
being looked at as a person.
- Yeah.
And I think you said a key
thing that I think is important.
It's not
about you accepting them. It's that you
feel like they won’t accept you.
- Right. Right. Exactly.
- And those two things really,
really aren't the same.
You know, I was really glad that I am
able to talk to you because honestly, when
I saw that you protested in California,
you were super heavy on my heart because
I thought about when I interviewed you
for my show, we were talking about death.
- Mmhmm.
- And you said that you were almost desensitized to it.
- The idea of people dying was something that had
made you numb cuz you had seen it so much.
So what is it like for you to see
Black people be murdered by police?
- I mean, it’s...it's a thing that, like, even with
this last situation—you know, rest in
peace to George Floyd—
when that situation happened and,
you know, I started seeing
all the protests, all, you know,
the looting, you just started
to see everything transpire.
I remember I called my mom one night.
I asked her, I said, I was, I
think I was three years old
when the Watts riot happened,
when the Rodney King beating happened.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- And I just wanted to ask her how,
“What was I doing at three years old?”
You know, cuz especially me, I
have a three-year-old daughter
and a seven-year-old daughter.
And I remember one night, I had the
news on, I'm seeing all the fires
and all the buildings on fire.
And then I see my kids sitting
there, and they’re really not knowing
and understanding what's going on.
So I put myself in their shoes, and I
remember I called my mom, and I asked myself
what was going on. And it gave
me a perspective on what type of
lifestyle I was living and grew
up in, of that being the norm.
And it was more so like,
“Yeah, you were sitting there
playing.” But, you know, so much
after that transpired and became worse
and worse in my lifetime till it made me feel
these senseless ties to certain tragedies
because, you know, you gotta keep going.
You gotta keep moving. You gotta keep
pushing, you know? And it
was one of those things to where, you
know, they didn't have it figured
out, but it was more so like,
“Yeah, that's what the police do.”
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- So growing up, it was more so
me knowing and feeling like,
“Oh, that's the norm,” or “The police,
oh, they just can't wait to catch a
Black, Black man doing something wrong
so they could do this to you.”
You know what I mean?
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- This is way before cameras and all this filming stuff was going on.
It was always, like, growing up was
taught to me was, like, “By all means,
if you see the police,
let them pass by, then
go about your business.”
You know, it gave me an
uncomfortable factor because
growing up, it was so normal
to think and fear the police because
you didn't wanna end up, like, in
a situation like that with them.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
As, as this has happened, I think
people are seeing that Black
people aren't surprised that it's
happening because we grow up,
we grew up with these talks of
what you do when you see a cop and
that a lot of cops will hurt you.
- Right.
- So it isn't an element of surprise.
It's more of like, “Oh, this happened again.”
- Right.
Yeah.
- And I think a lot of trauma comes with that.
You know, knowing that if a white
person sees a cop, they feel safe.
- [DeMar:] Yep.
- I don't think I've ever seen a cop
and been like, “Oh, like, I'm safe.”
- [DeMar:] Right.
- I'm like, “Oh, I gotta go in another lane.”
- [DeMar:] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
And that's a conversation that
I think I'm glad is being had now.
- [DeMar:] Mmhmm.
- Just the way that we all grow up
and our relationship to authority
and knowing that—when I say
authority, I mean cops, but I also
mean white people—
- [DeMar:] Yeah.
- And the privilege and power that white people have.
Our relationship to that authority is kind of coming to the forefront.
- Mmhmm.
- You also said something in our interview
that you had to grow up very quickly.
And you had to understand things that
a kid isn't supposed to understand.
What are some things that you were referring to?
- Death. You know,
early on, at five, six years old,
I lost my uncle to gang violence.
I lost another uncle to gang violence.
I remember going to
funerals and, you know, seeing my mother
cry countless nights, countless days
to where, you know, I remember one year
my mama went to 15, 20 funerals, you
know? And it got to a point to where to
this day, I...I don't like funerals
because they were so...they came up so
frequently through, through my youth,
you know, and that was something to where
people don't understand the
feeling of going to school,
and you sit next to a friend, and that
same night, you hearing that friend was
murdered and you sitting in that same
desk that next day, and he's not there,
and you realize he’s not coming back here.
He didn't transfer to another school.
He didn't—he wasn't sick.
Like, he's not coming back, period.
You know?
To deal with that and
to comprehend with that,
I think people really don't understand
unless you go through it, how hard
it is. And it puts you in a space to
where either it could break you down,
or you going to build up
this wall inside of you
that gives you the extra
strength to keep pushing and
just wanna make it out and not
be in that position anymore to keep
dealing with this type of feeling.
You know, I lost my best
friend in high school
to murder. You know, all these
things to where I haven't
even had a developmental yet,
and I'm comprehending the worst thing
possible that a kid could go through.
So with that, it's definitely something that—that definitely leaves, leaves,
a scar inside of you for a long time.
So,
um, it was tough.
Like I said, you know, I've
been an advocate for, you know, depression.
And a lot of that stems
from my, from my childhood—
things that I never addressed.
And, you know, I think at this
point of time going on in the
world, there's so much going on.
It's so much. It's
definitely traumatizing.
You know, when you turn on the news,
and you see so much negativity. You
seeing the police do this to us over
and over and over, and you seeing
innocent people being killed over and
over and over. You know, it's just, it's
just a time that, that—an opportunity
for us to all come together, not just
celebrities, people in general, and voice
how they feel and their opinion
and really make a change.
- You talk about the trauma of like
turning on the TV and seeing bad
things and be looking at your phone
and seeing Black people being murdered.
- Mmhmm.
- When I've been talking to Black people,
I've really just been asking, like, "Are you OK?"
- Right, right.
- So, I mean, are you OK,
really?
- Yeah, it's tough. In my mind it's
like, how can we be OK?
You know, and I asked myself,
something the other day on TV, and I was
just like, it was a newscaster, she
was talking to a Black man,
and he was expressing his frustration.
And through his frustration, you know,
he was using cuss words here and there.
And the newscaster on TV was
like, "Oh, we gotta cut him off.
He using too much profanity."
And in my mind, I'm sitting there
watching and I'm like, "But you could
pick up your phone, and we seeing
officers killing unarmed people.
So you, you undermining
how the way this man expressed his
frustration because he tired of seeing
people die for nothing?"
And it was like, "Really?"
That just shows me right there
you don't know what it's like
to walk in our shoes, to be a
Black person. You know what I mean?
- [Taylor:] Mmhmm.
- You worried about him saying a cuss word?
You should be more worried about
being able to go to your phone and
seeing so many people killed for nothing.
Like that's what's...that's the
type of stuff that trips me out.
You know what I mean?
And it's like, how can we be OK with that,
when you seeing that every day or, or
you don't see people sympathizing
what it's like to be Black?
You know what I mean?
- Absolutely.
- Like, that's my frustration.
And I don't think my
frustration will change until
people could get some sort of idea and
sympathize with that and start to begin
to help
with us as a collective group.
That's the only way, you know,
other—if you don't do that, it's
going to be that frustration.
It's going to be that aggression,
you know, because that's all, that's
all we know. Especially when it's
something that we're passionate about,
and we're passionate about our people.
So, we gotta take care of
that, and the best way to do it
is we all come together and do it
with every race.
- And you make a good point with this white woman's
reaction to the Black man is, white
people cannot police
how we feel right now.
- Right.
- Not only because they'll never understand
it, but because the only thing that
we have to give is the emotion.
- [DeMar:] Right.
- It's the emotion that's
carrying us through.
It's the emotion that
makes protests successful.
It's the emotion that brings change.
So the more a white person
feels uncomfortable with
how we express ourselves,
it's really just them saying they're
uncomfortable with the movement.
- Right.
Right. That's all it is.
- Yeah.
We need that.
It's,
it's our biggest power right now, is each
other and how we're looking after each
other and how those emotions manifest.
So I understand why you'd be frustrated
to hear that. I'm frustrated.
I'm frustrated to even hear that
a woman tried to police his, his
words when we're trying to change
people's actions. You know, the
words are the base level of it.
So, yeah, I think a lot of Black
people—like, you know, I had a thought
when someone had asked me if I was
OK, my thought was like, "If I'm
killed, will the person be arrested?"
- Yeah.
That's—it's all these questions
that everybody that I see asks
are legitimate questions that we
still cannot get an answer to.
- Mmhmm.
- But you wonder why we're frustrated, get upset,
and want to question our actions. You know? I'm, like, come on.
Not, not just with this situation.
A year ago, 10 years ago, 20.
This has been going on.
You know what I mean?
It's been going on.
Like, I grew up seeing it, and
I'm 30 years old.
I can imagine how—my
dad is from Louisiana.
Like he grew up in whole
segregated South and everything.
So up until I was 12 years old, he
used to take me to Louisiana with him.
All the time.
Like, once every summer till I was 12
years old, and I didn't really understand
it until I got older and I start to see
the segregation of how it was in the South, and
the obstacles my dad had to go through,
had to deal with, had to—it's like,
all these things.
And I used to always question, like,
me being from the city, being a city
boy, I used to hate going through
the country, but that was one of the
lessons that showed me so much as a
kid, because it was, it's like, I couldn't imagine
growing up in that. I couldn't imagine growing up.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
Like, I couldn't.
We think, we think it's crazy now.
Like it's, it's, our parents and
grandparents went through so
much, and now I look at it
like this is an ultimate opportunity for
us to, to do something incredible, like,
incredible, and really make a change.
- Yeah.
How has your mental health
been throughout this?
- Um, I've been managing it.
I think, I think for me, just being more
mature and understanding how to
reach out and speak to other individuals
that may not know how to handle—
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- Things has been helpful for me. You
know, before it, I used to close
in and become sheltered and kinda
steer away and shy away from
everything, you know, and try
to figure it out on my own.
I think more so for me, I've been more so,
wanna lend a hand, and that's
been therapeutic for me to be
able to have others listen to me.
And I give whatever,
experience and whatever honesty that I'm
dealing with and try to share that.
You know, I think that's been
definitely beneficial for me.
Especially without having, you know, basketball all this time.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- So that's been something
that's been helpful to me.
- One thing that I think, you know,
I admire about you and a lot of the
Black men that I end up speaking to
is you find a lot of power and vulnerability—
- Mmhmm.
- And understanding that
emotion can really help you. But
there's also a conversation to be had
about Black men growing up feeling
as though they can't be emotional.
- Right.
- Was that your experience?
- And if it was your experience,
how did you shift away from that?
- I grew up in Compton. It was a tough time, man, like,
it was a tough time because every
single day was worse than the day
previous, you know?
- [Taylor:] Mmhmm.
- And it became such a normal, it became such a normal, normal time.
You know, I talked to a lot of
my friends that I grew up with,
and we really sit back and
trip on how crazy the times were,
but we didn't look at it like
that because that's all we knew.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- You know, for me, what helped me was
when I had my first daughter. That showed
me a sense of empathy, compassion,
love and care and a whole element of
something that I never, I never really
had. You know, I always had it within
my mother, but my mother was, my
mother is, she's one of the strongest
women I ever came across, you know,
so she always had that, you know. My
grandma was loving and caring, but she
was always like, "All right, you mess up, I'mma whoop
your ass now," you know what I mean?
-Yeah, trust me, I know what you mean.
- Yeah, so, you know, when I, when I got
older and I had my daughter, and it
was somebody who needed to lean on me,
it gave me that sense of love and care and
empathy, and it kinda knocked down
and softened the wall that I, that I
had built up for so long, you know?
So, that helped me, you
know, but it definitely should be
other ways, and we should feel OK.
Especially when you know you made
it through the rough times in life,
to understand that you're a
man that you never, never have
to doubt or question yourself.
It should be OK to be
vulnerable because we need it.
Mentally, we need it.
-  Yeah. Absolutely.
Absolutely.
And I think mentally we need it.
The world needs it.
Everybody needs it.
Um, you've talked about your daughters.
How are you going to talk to
your daughters about being Black?
- I just tell them how beautiful—you
know, one thing since day one, before they
could talk I always expressed to my
daughters, understand how beautiful
they are, how intelligent they are,
how, you know, confident they should be.
How, never let nothing
negative knock them down.
So, you know, so many, so many
positives that especially
a Black woman needs to hear
on a daily basis.
- [Taylor:] Mmhmm.
- So their entire life is, they
got nothing from that from me,
like, that's all I give
them every single day.
So they understand that
when some B.S. come their way,
it don't even faze them.
You know, be strong Black women,
understand what you need to do, how you
need to do it, but it's going to be obstacles
that you're going to need to face,
and these, this—make sure you assess
it, understand it and proceed with
however you need to proceed
with it, you know, and just giving
them an understanding of that.
You know?
So, as long as they're knowledgeable
of understanding the wrongs
and rights of, of life,
you know,
I feel like I'll be OK
once they become older
Black women on this earth.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I obviously saw those very powerful images
of you and Kendrick Lamar and Russell
Westbrook out protesting in Compton.
And I was able to talk to
Kendrick about it, but he's like,
"You know, now I want action.
I want to figure out what I can do
to help, you know, past protesting."
But just seeing you guys out there,
I think meant a lot to so many
people, but how did that come to be?
Like, how did you three get together and
say, "OK, let's protest. Let's meet here"?
Walk me through that.
- I don't, I don't, maybe people
didn't see it. It was a
couple—probably about a week ago,
it was a couple of
cops in Compton that had
beat up a young Black male
one night. And it was all over the news.
And it was one of those
moments to where I called,
I actually called my high school
coach. And we was talking about it,
and I was like, “Let's figure out
something we can do for the city,
you know, to unite the city.”
Because at that time, Compton
hadn't had a protest yet. You
know, major parts of L.A. had.
Um, and I just told him this is another
opportunity for us to be able to
come together and show, you know,
one of the key cities in L.A. that
we united in and it’s staying together.
I fell asleep.
I woke up the next day.
My high school coach
had talked to the mayor.
Umm.
Next thing you know, we
put the protest together.
Um, we put it out.
I'm sending it to everybody
I knew.
And we
went to the protest.
You know, Russ has been
one of the close friends of
mine since I can remember.
And he always been an advocate when
it comes to things like this—his father,
his parents, everybody, you know,
has been one of those, one of those
things. And Kendrick, I mean, he's
from Compton, you know? So it's,
it was a no-brainer knowing, you know, he
was going to come and support. And,
you know, Kendrick, you barely see Kendrick
these days.
- Yeah, I know. Yeah.
- For him to come out and
show that and give that inspiration,
it's great because Kendrick has been an
inspiration for, you know, this generation, kids
coming up in Compton.
So, you know, it was a beautiful moment.
A moment that I'll cherish for the
rest of my life, being able to be
a part of that and giving whatever
positivity and inspiration I could to it.
- Yeah.
No, it's very powerful for people
to see those that they look at often and
look too often, you know, protesting.
So, no, thank you absolutely
for doing that.
I put out a report
recently talking about the Zoom
calls NBA players have been on.
I know you guys have already done
one, and there's about to be another
Zoom call just about what you all
can do to unify and take a stand.
- [DeMar:] Mmhmm.
- I assume you have, but have you been
on those Zoom calls, privy to them? And
just tell me what they have been like.
- Very intense. I mean, people know us for being
athletes but don't understand how
competitive we are when it comes to
other things and how vocal, how intelligent
every single guy that's
in this profession is.
And every one of those
guys has incredible ideas,
passion, will to want to put a
foot forward to making a change.
You know, every step of
the way. You seen guys
been doing it for years now. You
know, guys like Melo, CP, you know,
Bron, D-Wade. It's all these guys that's
coming together and even teaching
and bringing up the young guys to
understand how to go about this thing.
So it's definitely been
a passionate thing,
in passionate conversations on how
to push this thing forward, you know.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- Whenever you can get a collective,
guys that's the ultimate competitors,
and put their minds to something,
I really believe something great
going to come out of it.
- I've heard that Kyrie has been very vocal
in this and leading a lot of discussions.
Are there any other guys that
you have, like, kind of seen
emerge as leaders in this?
- Right,
yeah,
Yeah.
You know, a lot of guys
that's quiet, stay to themselves,
you know, they, they stepping
forward, you know, putting
a foot forward and understanding,
like, this is an opportunity for us
to really show who we really are.
And you see it.
You know, like I said, we know how a lot
of us are, but the world don't. And
seeing these guys stepped forward,
showing their true character is
going to be even more amazing.
- I'm sure
there have to be many more
conversations, but just in your
opinion, what do you think will
happen and what do you want to happen?
- Um, in my opinion, I think something
that hasn't been done, um, through,
you know, all our leaders that set the
groundwork for changing, you know,
equality and justice, just everything,
I think it's finally, finally going
to be able to switch and
lean to the right way.
To fairness, to how it
shoulda always been, you know?
And I think you definitely going to see
the world come together and all the
people that's against this be exposed
and be outnumbered by all
the greatness that everybody else is
trying to do for the next generation.
So I really truly believe
that it will be a change.
And it won't be another 10, 20,
30 years of this madness because
of the power of the people stepping
forward with undeniably—proof.
Like, you know?
- It's right there in front of you.
- It's right there in front, it's there for us to
understand and take advantage of and run
with and put it out there to be fair.
And I truly believe that. I truly
believe that.
- Popovich has been
such a voice throughout this.
And always is.
He always gives his thoughts on politics,
social justice, racial injustice.
What conversations does he
have with you guys internally?
Not just about racial issues, but
the role that white people play
in those issues.
- Man, since Day 1
I got with the Spurs, Pop
was the most conscious person
when it comes to society that I came across,
especially a white person, you know.
I had the opportunity to play with
Dwane Casey, that's from Kentucky.
He always used to express how
he grew up in the South, how it was, how
segregation was and everything.
And he always used to speak about,
you know, that injustice and all
those things that came with, you
know, growing up back in the day.
And I learned so much from him.
And the flip side, to go play
with a coach, a white coach,
that feels the same way,
like he was a Black man, of
understanding the unfairness.
Um,
how much
things need to change. It's
Pop, man. It's been so many days
where we had come in and we think
we have film, and Pop would sit us
down and show us something about
a crooked cop or a man
losing his life for nothing.
How messed up the system is, how—just
all these things that's been going on.
He been making us aware of this, even
if you wasn't paying attention or
as passionate as the next person, he put
it on the forefront every single day.
There wasn't a day that went
by where Pop does not,
you know, so it's not surprised me when
I see him speak up and say these things.
Behind closed doors, he'd do this on a
daily basis to show us how messed-up
of a society that we live in and how
it's on us to change it, you know?
- Your team meetings would be video.
- Yeah, he will, he will show a clip
or whatever a topic is of something,
and it will put life
in perspective for you.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- You know, and it's one of
the most incredible things
that a lot of people wouldn't know
unless you play for him, that it
definitely goes beyond basketball. And
to see a white man of his stature,
he'd be the first one to jump out
there and he don't care what no
one else thinks.
- [Taylor:] Mhmm.
- He speaks the truth, and you see it
in his words, you know.
You gotta, you gotta love and
respect an individual like that.
- Yeah.
Well, when it comes to basketball,
obviously a lot of the talk has been,
do players even want to play with all of
this injustice happening. In your opinion
and what you've gathered from the calls,
what makes people nervous about sitting
out? And what has that
conversation been?
- I think the conversation is, it's such
a tricky time that nobody, nobody
expected or could foresee, with
the pandemic, with, you know,
everything that's been going on,
it's just been, it's just been a
tricky, tricky year so far, you know?
And
it's so many mixed feelings.
And in terms of, you know, how
different and difficult it's going
to be, attempting to play, with everything
that's going on that's bigger than us,
bigger than, bigger than basketball,
bigger than just playing a game,
you know.
So it's hard to shift all of a sudden
without playing the sports we love,
with everything going on,
to all of a sudden, our focus and our
mindset has been towards, you know, trying
to make a change and make a difference.
Umm.
So it's definitely, it's definitely
mixed emotions, I think, to, we just
trying to get to a place of settlement,
of understanding, like, OK, where
can we put our energy to and still
be focused on other things at the
same time. Because we, you know, we
still not sure how it's going to work
when we go to Orlando, you know?
- [Taylor:] Right.
- There are still so many question marks—
- A lot.
- —of the not knowing
and not feeling all the way comfortable.
So, you know, just through human
nature, there'd definitely be hesitation
there, you know, because you just
don't know, you know? It's not
like, aight, it's going back to regular.
We playing in our arenas.
We doing this.
Now you saying we've been here for this
amount of time, locked in this place.
All right, now you got to calm
guys down of understanding
all that's going on.
How we going to do this?
- [Taylor:] Mmhmm.
- Are we away from our families?
So, like I said, there's so many
mixed emotions. But I know for a
fact, guys want to play basketball.
You know, it's just, it's just trying
to get through all these emotions
of things that's going on.
- I will lastly—I end all of these with
the same question. And that is: Words mean
different things to different people.
How do you define "America"?
- Being Black,
you have to be strong enough to
bring up the next person behind you
to be even greater, to make life
better for anyone to come after you.
That's what America means to me. Being
Black, putting yourself in a position
to be able to pull up somebody below you
to do something better than you, to make life
much more better for the next person.
That's,
that's how I look at it.